hello everyone i'm kyle
um i work at cloudflare i'm a systems
engineer and one of the things i work on
a lot is
uh the crypto side of things for our
security stuff
so truth be told the past month i've
been in c doing uh tpm stuff
but we just released a package called
cfssl
which has a lot of ssl toolkit stuff
that we've built
to be less of a pain than the openssl
tools
so tonight i just want to give you guys
kind of a brief introduction to
the different packages for cryptography
and go kind of let you guys know what's
available
um i'm going to talk a little bit of
give like kind of a brief background
about crypto just for people who may not
uh may not really know much about it and
then we'll just kind of look at some
packages
and some examples and then
i think we'll have i'll post the slides
to the meetup page tonight
you guys can look at it afterwards too
and this time i kind of gave this talk
at the last go session
and now i have notes based on how that
went
uh so what are we trying to do first of
all like with crypto right we have three
goals
you want confidentiality you don't want
people to be able to eavesdrop on your
messages you want people to be able to
read them
you want integrity to make sure that
nobody is tampered with it or messed
with it
and you want authenticity to make sure
you're talking to who you think you're
talking to
and you need all three to have a secure
system if you have integrity and not
authenticity
i can read what you're saying if you
have confidentiality and not
or and authenticity but not integrity
does this work
i don't want to just suddenly boom so
all right
so if you have a system with
confidentiality and authenticity uh but
no integrity
it means i can change messages and route
and i don't necessarily have to know
what they are
to still have an effect on them i mean
if i have confidentiality
and integrity that's great the message
is secret
i can't change it but i could forge
something or pretend to be
who you think you're talking to but it's
actually me uh
so oops so there's actually a couple
different kinds of crypto
right we have symmetric which is what
you guys may think of when you think of
cryptography
um it's like aes and um hmac and stuff
like that and they're very fast building
blocks
but it's really hard to share keys with
them and sharing keys like this with
symmetric
cryptography is like sharing a password
um then we also have public key
cryptography like rsa or elliptic curves
and this is a lot easier i have a secret
that i keep and don't give to anybody
and i
give everybody a public part of my
secret
so then everybody can use the public
part to send messages to me
and we can build secure systems that way
too
and really we want to mix the two
together we want to use
uh public key cryptography which is slow
but really nice to change
or exchange keys we want to use that to
exchange uh symmetric keys
then once we've exchanged those
symmetric keys often called the shared
key
we can then move to a lot faster crypto
so
one of the things that's really nice is
i came from a background at sea
and i'm used to using libgrypt or
openssl
and it's a mess so go
has some really nice crypto packages
they're very clean they're very easy to
use
so here's a couple of them right here i
guess we have
different tools for all this stuff
things that
were a lot more difficult to do in c or
in python maybe
i don't know if you guys have python
ever mess with pi crypto it can be kind
of a pain to get started with
uh go is actually a lot easier than that
so for random data right that's the
basis of all crypto stuff
if you want to get random data do not
use math rand
it's not meant for cryptographically
secure stuff there is however crypto
rand
which uses your operating system's
random number generator facilities for
to do things securely
and that's what you should use
brand.reader is an i o reader
we all love i o readers right they're
awesome so you can use it just like you
would
any other file or reader at all
and so it's actually pretty simple just
like you would read
stuff from a file you would read it from
that i o reader now let's see who can
actually
run it once
okay so we got some cool numbers there
they're random i promise
we'll see again we get different numbers
i hope
or maybe not
so this is running on this is running on
app engine and i'm guessing the sandbox
is kind of like yeah here's a random
number generator it's real random
so the fun part is we'll all get the
same rsa keys when we run the
key generation use that for secrets
um hashing stuff right the shaw hashing
functions
um there's stuff for that and they're
really easy to use
there is an md5 package please don't use
it for crypto stuff
unless you're implementing a
specification and it says use this
don't use it and try to avoid shot one
it's there's no official weaknesses in
it yet but it's starting to show its age
and we have much better options for that
um and we use hashing for building
blocks and a lot of things
uh so here's uh the example of the
hashing stuff
so you call new for whatever kind of
hash that you need
and it gives you a new writer
so you can write buy slices to it buy
slices to it and then you just
call some on it and as you can see here
here's our data that came into it and
then here's a digest of it
i will show you i run it again to show
more random data but that doesn't
actually do anything
so hmax when we're doing secret key
stuff or symmetric cryptography this is
what we use for integrity and
authentication
um so there's other there's other ways
to do this but this is well vetted
the well-known way to do it and the
package for doing this and go
is really easy to use so you really you
can use this
and that'll that'll get you a lot of
secure give you a strong foundation to
build on
um it is based on a hash function so we
use it in conjunction with uh maybe shot
um and you need to randomly generate a
key for this or
get a key some other way and that
package is crypto hmac
um you can see here the rule of thumb
for generating a hmac key
is to just use the size of the the
digest we're using so shock 256 is 32
bytes
we'll generate a 32 byte key for it and
then hmac
up here you just tell it
hey we're using shot 256 here's my key
write some data to this
writer and then get the sum back
and uh there's actually functions for
comparing
the h max to make sure that it's done
securely there are actual attacks that
you can do if you don't do it right um
and the go
package authors adam langley has kindly
provided a secure way to do this so you
don't have to worry about implementing
it yourself
maybe yeah so we just ran generate some
random data
and we can generate uh tags from that
the
the output of the hmac is called the tag
make sure they're not the same
and i think that the sandbox actually
broke this so
cool uh but there's some example code
that we'll use it um when you guys get a
chance to see the slides later
it'll be a you guys can look at that
uh so secret creed cryptography how to
use aes and all that
it's hard it's really tricky there's a
lot of subtleties to it
and there's too much to cover in this
talk so i'm not going to
use this package called sodium chloride
or knackle
or whatever however you pronounce it
it's fast it's done by a respected
cryptographer who also has a reputation
for writing good code
um if you need to use aes use keys are
or something like that or find somebody
who has experience with this
um it's it's really easy to mess up
this is my least favorite package crypto
x 509
it's certificate handling
as of go 1.3 there's also certificate
signature requests
which is nice to have you can actually
do the full generate a key
generate your signature or your
certificate request and then generate a
certificate all within go now
and before to do that middle step you
have to use openssl or something similar
it's all in go now and it also has
functions for
serializing and parsing um your private
keys and public keys
to the to the known standard so you're
not trying to like how do i compact this
maybe throw in some json nope just
this has got everything you need you
laugh
but so password hashing
all right you just throw it in md5 write
your password md5 and store that
no so
there are a couple of things here
depending on what you're trying to do if
what you need is a secret key like
you want to use a password to encrypt a
file and we're going to use script
it's really good for doing that it does
require you to generate a random salt
though 16 bytes or 32 bytes maybe
um and you need that salt which is not a
secret to
to get the same key back from that
password um
so one of the things that that's really
or one of the ways that you can do that
is just
when you have encrypted data you just
prepend your salt to that
and that's part of your new format it's
really easy to use too and we'll see
that in a sec
and then decrypt if you're storing a
password bcrips format
includes the salt and all the other
information that you need to
reconstitute that
so it's a good choice for when you want
to store passwords you don't have to
have a separate
um you know column for salt and hash
you can just store this be crypt result
so here is password hashing this
actually won't run um it's the one
there's two examples that are based on
script and one on b-crypt that won't run
on this
app engine thing so i can't preview how
cool it is
but you can see here it's pretty simple
i have a
uh cleverly chosen password and uh
we just call generate from password with
a cost function and if you read the docs
it'll tell you what
good cost functions to use are so just
you read up your docs before you go
throwing throwing this in your code
and then it also has a compare hash and
password so you just give it your
password
and the previously generated decrypt
hash and it will
tell you whether or not that's right
if you want to generate a secret key
from a password again you have your
cleverly chosen password
a random salt i use 16 bytes here
and then we call script and there are
some default parameters and there's
more choices that you have for this
and the defaults are on the docs you
could also read the rfc or whatever that
if you are into that kind of thing um
and
they will kind of affect how long it
takes to get a key from that password
so in other words if you use stronger
parameters somebody trying to brute
force it is going to have a lot harder
time doing it
so you see here it just gives you a byte
slice that you can then
use as your key
so i did a quick benchmark here just to
show you guys some of the common
parameters that are chosen and how it
affects password speed
um when if i could run it it would be a
little bit more interesting but
i don't think this can be useful with
the sandboxing i didn't think about that
sodium chloride i think is the official
pronunciation for this
there is a go package for it it uses
something
or a cypher cipher called
salsa 20 and it uses a mac function
that's not hmac
but they're both well known well proven
and it's very very fast
in fact it's if you don't have hardware
support for aes
in your machine this is actually going
to be a lot faster
and it's it's really it's really solid
code
and you use a little bit different
terminology when you look through the
docs just know that when you see seal
that means
encrypt with authentication and open
means decrypt and make sure
or check the authentication on it
uh here's an example i don't let's get
this one over on
nope
okay so when what cipher should you use
the answer
whatever the rfc says um if you don't
know which one to pick
then you should go with whatever it is
you're trying to implement says to use
um if you're building your own system
then you're probably going to go with
uh sodium chloride like i said before
elliptic curves
are faster if you need to pick a public
key algorithm
but we haven't studied them and we don't
have as much experience
in understanding the security properties
of elliptic curves as we do rsa
so you have to kind of balance those
needs there
i have some cipher choices here for tls
you should prefer
uh ephemeral ecdh rsa using aes 128 gcm
and sha 256
sounds like nonsense right you probably
just want to read this off the slide
later on
but these we picked these uh especially
like at cloudflare where we put a lot of
thought into
which ciphers are going to be the best
for us to serve to people on a large
scale
and these we feel are the best
performance and security
um balance for that and eventually there
will be an improvement to salsa 20
called cha cha 20
and that'll be great for mobile clients
because it's faster
than aes and those clients do not have
aes support usually
on their processors i mean when you're
picking um
like for tls choices or for your ssl
stuff
you really need to have boards there's
forward secrecy so you'll see something
like ecdhe
um there's no excuse anymore not to have
that just pick one of the ones with
ecdhe
um and what's forward secrecy basically
if somebody compromises
your private key then the previous
messages that they have may have
captured
cannot be decrypted that those messages
are secure against that
the fastest one and the most commonly
used now is probably elliptic curves
for various reasons mostly speed and
performance
but you should pick something like that
if you're using tls
certificate chains are also the bane of
my existence from
working on tf ssl um where every ca has
their own special and unique way of
screwing this up
yeah so basically what you have is
um i'm on example.net
and i want to get an ssl certificate
okay
so then i have to go to say globalsign
who's going to issue me a certificate
from a private key but they don't want
to put their master
key um out in the wild like on a
computer that's actually
live because if they lose that that is a
huge cost for them to
reissue it and to prove that it belongs
to them um there's a lot that goes into
that
so they take their master key and they
keep it offline
it never goes out on a network computer
or it stays in a hardware security
module
and then they have what's called an
intermediate certificate or
multiple intermediate certificates and
they sign this intermediate certificate
with this offline key and then they sign
your certificate
with this intermediate so if you want to
prove that a certificate belongs or was
issued by global sign
you walk the chain backwards i look at
your certificate
it says this was signed by global
science intermediate okay check the
signature against global science
intermediate
public key and then this intermediate
was signed by global science root key
and then they published the public key
they don't need to keep that secret
so i can look at their public key for
the root and the signature on this
intermediate
and uh say okay it matches or it doesn't
and if everything
matches up and lines up then we know
it's a trusted certificate
well trusted and reputable for varying
definitions
of both of those words there's root
pools in x 509
which are basically how you choose to um
or how you put in a bunch of
certificates that you say we trust these
ones
and you'll have an intermediate pool
that says these certificates
can be used in the middle of the chain
but they can't anchor a chain
and then you also have a root pool which
says these should be anchors
but probably should be anywhere else and
the default is your operating system
stores
and you'll find some really creative
ways that they the cas do this
you'll find older weaker keys that have
been
cross signed and all kinds of fun stuff
so
yeah that's this is one thing that is a
pet peeve of mine
um insecure skip verify have any of you
guys ever used this like turn this on
don't do it um so in the go session i
had the
uh samuel jackson you know turn on
insecure
insecure skip verify one more time just
don't
what happens is it bypasses all your
checks on authentication
so great you have uh if you remember
from the beginning we have
uh integrity and we have confidentiality
but what we don't have is authenticity
so you don't know that you're actually
talking to the server you think you're
talking to
so you are opened up to things like mad
in the middle attacks
where i can basically sit in between you
and you know gmail
and proxy things out and read your email
or
maybe get a password reset email you get
into some other
like your bank account so don't do it
because it's really easy to leave it on
in production
payment coding this just kind of like a
administrative sort of thing
is that in order to kind of get around
to maybe encoding issues with passing
binary data around
the standard format is to base64 the
binary data and then we put some headers
on it like it tells us whether it's a
certificate or maybe a private key
um and so the go package encoding pem
does all that handles all that you give
it a byte slice and you tell it what
kind of type it should be and it'll
format everything nicely for you
um so generating rsa keys is also pretty
easy you give it your rand reader
and you tell it how big of a key you
want and it will spit out a key for you
hopefully um so this is the was talking
about with the random number or the rng
on here
we're going to get the same key each
time so uh
so what i do is i generate a key
or it's a computational intensive and
this is one of the things about rsa is
it takes a while to do things
except for verifying signatures is
really fast
so that's one reason why people
sometimes choose elliptic curves over it
because it's slow but you'll just
generate a key maybe
marshall it out into something that you
can
send off as a uh generate a csr or
something like that
uh encrypting with rsa doesn't work like
most people think it does
because you normally think that i can
have this message like maybe an email
it's you know big long message and
then i just pass it to rsa and it
encrypts it um rsa actually is limited
if you're using it right as to how much
you can encrypt
it's on the order of 300 bytes so this
is what i was talking about earlier we
agree on a shared key and encrypt that
with rsa and then we switch to that
we want to start sending messages back
and forth um
so this is a little bit involved a
little bit more involved
we basically generate a random session
key um and
encrypt with rsa and then now we can
encrypt messages
with that session key
signing is is pretty similar you'll see
that in the go package there's two ways
to sign
or verify with rsa there is something
called pss the probabilistic signature
scheme
or pkcs version one 1.5
you should use the probabilistic
signature scheme pss
use the pkcs1 version 1.5
only if the rfc or the spec you're
implementing to says
hey use this there's
some math that goes into it that
basically the probabilistic scheme
is more secure generating ec dsa keys
this is what a lot of people use which
you'll receive for elliptic curves in
tls is using ecdsa within this curves
go provides uh three and maybe four
standard curves that should get you
through pretty much everything that
you're gonna need to do unless you're
doing bitcoin stuff
um and those curves are called like
pe256
and then there's one called p521 which
is not like a typo
which i thought it was the first time i
ran into it like oh you mistyped that
notes
it's actually 521 bits um and so they
kind of correspond to how strong the
symmetric ciphers you're using are
and again don't worry too much about
that just use what the spec says to use
and then you generate them kind of the
same way as you do with
rsa and i think we can actually run this
one it won't take too long
yes they're really fast a lot faster
than rsa
so and if we had seen the uh
the rsa key you know it would be down to
here so there's
they take up a lot more space they're
bigger keys so if space is a concern
or you really need the speed you're
going to go with elliptic curves
but again we don't understand the
security properties of them quite like
we do with
rsa so we have to balance that out
encrypting with these curves is
complicated
because we basically have to negotiate a
shared key
and then switch to symmetric crypto
i'm not going to cover that here because
it's a little bit more complicated
so again the sodium chloride library
also has elliptic curves but they work
differently
and the easiest way to use it is just to
use the functions in the
uh the package for uh ceiling messages
and opening messages and it'll handle
all the
all the lower level details for you you
don't even have to worry about
how you get the secret key or what the
secret key is
so you just generate key it'll give you
a public private key and throw an error
if something goes wrong
and then you conceal and then open the
messages
the one thing with this package is you
need to make sure you have a nonce which
is a number used once
uh it doesn't matter how you get that
number as long as it's only ever used
once
uh so you could start with zero and then
just you know keep going up by one
one one as long as you make sure that
both of you are agreeing on that number
and that you're never using it again
so there's some other interesting
packages as well that's open pgp
if you guys have seen key base i
actually wrote a key base half client
that handles a lot of the interaction
with the site using this open pgp
package so you can interact with
with those keys that way there's otr
which is a
messaging like instant messaging
encryption protocol
and then there's ssh which you can do
all the fun that you can with ssh
here's some real world projects you i
included if you guys want to look at
them later
um adam langley wrote pawn there's keys
are an open pgp key server
and then the cfssl that we released um
and i think that's all i have um
any questions
if i'm using like the standard http
package
and as a client and i do an https
request
somewhere how does do you know how the
cert
signing works and what happens
or whatever so as long as you are
validating which by default the package
will
it'll it'll check to see if the
certificate's invalid in a couple
different ways
but it won't do revocation checks i
don't think
so you might have to check to see if
it's revoked yourself
but there isn't really any signing that
goes in into that
and it's all negotiated in the protocol
which which
cyphers you're going to use
so for example with our cfssl tool that
we wrote
you can specify a bundle of certificates
and that will
that'll be your root bundle for example
and it'll load it up on start and say
okay here's all of our routes that we're
going to trust
and then we have intermediates that we
load up on startup too from a file
that's similar and then you can add
to that as you maybe as your program's
running maybe
like in our case there are times we run
into intermediates that we haven't seen
before
and as long as adding that intermediate
to the chain doesn't or it
still creates a valid chain we'll add
that intermediate to our pool
so it's not built into the binary
necessarily you have
you can but what most people are going
to do is load them from a file
does that answer the question is
by default it'll just use whatever your
operating system uses
so if you're using windows or linux or
mac
then you have the keychains or
certificate stores
built or that are distributed with it
does that answer is that okay cool
anybody else
yep
uh so the question is is it better to
use shot 256 versus shot 512
and the answer is you're going to use
whatever makes sense with um
with your your system that you're
building for example you need 32 bytes
of output or 64.
um a lot of what we do is take some data
and then kind of mix it up shuffle up to
get some more
randomized data from that and so maybe
we need 64 bytes
to get a 32 by encryption key and a 32
by
hmac key in that case you do shot 512.
there isn't really a difference
in terms of security one way or the
other
it's really i mean you're gonna have
less collisions with
sha 512 but it's not appreciable
anyone else
tuck your head between your tails and
run so it does
if your operating system um fails oh
yeah so what do you do if
rand reader fails and basi basically
that's a failure of your operating
system
so you should proceed very carefully um
you
probably just want to not do anything
until that comes back up
right basically what i did i kind of
just retry
i mean like is that what i'm supposed to
do yeah you just
what you you don't want to use bad um or
like have non-random data so if it fails
maybe delay for a second and then try
again
or you know some delay time
anybody else
thank you